according to Nancy Pelosi so she just
did an interview today in which she said
this I'm not for impeachment this is
news I'm going to give you some news
right now because I haven't said this to
any press person before but since you
asked and I've been thinking about this
impeachment is so divisive to the
country that unless there's something so
compelling and overwhelming and
bipartisan I don't think we should go
down that path because it divides the
country and he's just not worth it so
setting aside that last dig on he's just
not worth it no impeachment well she's a
smart cookie if I can still say that in
this era
she knows impeachment will do three
things it'll bring out the best in Trump
cuz he seems to rebound from antagonists
like the fight yeah he likes to fight
too it'll generate sympathy and anger
and turn him into a folk hero which is
why he might even like the impeachment
process because look what it did to Bill
Clinton three it handicaps attempts
because they spread themselves too thin
they should be trying to win instead of
trying to impeach they got two years to
figure this thing out and she's saying
look you know you try to win an election
stop chasing this guy yeah one you think
she's trying to send a message to the
rank-and-file that we're gonna focus on
governing until we have she said if it
was compelling overwhelming and
bipartisan then we would do it right but
I think that what she's saying is in
fact Dana a lot of the requests for for
example material information from the
White House a lot of the continuing
investigations that are going on she's
saying let's put our money on that as
part of the 20/20 effort because
basically what you're going to see is
they're going to say hey this is still a
problem for president Trump why put
ourselves in the way of president
Trump's arrows in terms of saying
impeachment these people just did trying
to undo the 2016 election what do you
think she's trying to help the Democrats
addressing what helps the Democrats and
it helps the country and rarely do those
things coexist equally because it will
divide the country if it's not an
overwhelming a high crime and
misdemeanor and if the Democrats over
reach an impeach on something is
partisan is you know his taxes or
something like that or stormy Daniels
you're gonna see a huge backlash and
she's not gonna have the gavel for that
long I'm not saying she's old she's
seasoned she's seen this before Lyons
you can she's very wise you can have
these house things flip in a heartbeat
on war
corruption and on overage and remembers
the last time the Democrats overreached
on Obamacare they lost their house this
is why the Democrats took the house back
us because she sent this message out to
them long before people went to the
polls in November if you go back and
look at the messaging she said cut it
with the impeachment talk and then she
can let Jerry Nadler and Adam Schiff and
do whatever they want to about document
requests and calling my son but they
will not be uttering that word right
well we'll see what happens
[Music]